the concept of thinking in terms of a
distant future that we can arrive at is
one that I find an exciting and
necessary we found that if you take
people out of the city you take them out
of cellphone range you put them in a
context that can start conversation and
that's really what the clock project is
about it's about starting different
types of conversation that you not
normally have and this place really does
that and you get up into the crystalline
forest and you're looking at Bristol
County step that were probably saplings
when the great pyramids were they
four or five thousand years ago and it
immediately achieves the goal that the
clock is trying to achieve and so we
wanted to see how people react to that
and see how we can capitalize on what's
already natural beauty and power of the
site and how we can enhance in this it's
actually pretty rare that I made
pants as a natural site we want to show
that
the long now has always been an
exercising sort of stretching your mind
and accepting responsibility for more or
at least grasping more in your in your
thinking patterns and this is a natural
place for so doing that spatially too so
for being here and when you stand up on
top of that mountain and you look for
hundreds of miles in every direction you
really have a sense of how small an
individual human is on the earth and
it's pretty unspoiled stopped if you see
in every direction and so for us it's a
sense of responsibility to for kind of
keeping that in spoiled
it's a monument to an idea it certainly
reflects thoughtfulness that I deeply
appreciate and I'm really delighted to
be able to play a small part
there's this weird dichotomy in the
sense that we really do want to build
something that's gonna last for 10,000
years we really do want to leave this
for the future but that's not really why
we're doing it we're really doing it so
that people today to get them to think
to get them to expand their time
horizons so that they can think not just
about this quarter this fiscal year this
presidential elections but to get them
to think about these long-term problems
I think the conversation that took place
out in the desert was the continuation
of one that's been going for a while and
that is going to be carrying on for a
long time yeah and and yes I was part of
it but so was everyone else who attended
and so is everyone else who comes too
long now events and who becomes a member
and who watches the videos or listen to
the podcasts or engages with these ideas
at any level because it is finally not
about the origins of those ideas but
about you know what we do with
one of the most interesting aspects of
being up there was sort of watching a
community begin to congeal before your
eyes and this is a multi-part and very
long term process obviously but there
are milestones along the way where you
can say you know something special
happened in this journey you know and I
think last week's trip to the Fox site
was one of those movies